the pandemic did a number on supply
chains and now there's escalating
violent conflict in ukraine
the war is hitting stock and bond
markets around the world pumping up the
already high price of oil which drives
up the cost of just about everything
else according to economists just on the
oil and transportation cost piece this
is huge
transportation costs affect pretty much
everything we consume seven in ten
businesses across canada found supply
chain challenges got worse this winter
more than 90 percent expect things to
stay the same or go downhill this spring
the top three supply chain headaches
delivery delays higher input costs and
supply shortages the war in ukraine
threatens all of it russia and ukraine
make up a third of all wheat exports and
while that won't hinder your ability to
find a loaf of bread it's going to drive
up the price tag and the cost of a slew
of other food items and that's bad news
for household budgets especially those
already struggling overall for consumers
this is quite hurtful the auto industry
has been grappling with higher costs for
steel and other materials but now a
workaround for key minerals normally
sourced from eastern europe is in the
card which isn't ideal according to the
head of the automotive parts and
manufacturers association there isn't a
shortage of supplies of those critical
minerals just that you'd have to
resource them from places you don't want
to source them from like china europe
stands to bear the economic brunt of the
conflict particularly germany because of
its economic ties to both countries a
knock to german assembly lines where
critical parts and technology for
vehicles are produced creates a ripple
effect the semiconductor industry is
bracing for more disruption depending on
what happens next if this conflict in
ukraine continues to escalate and and
europe is pulled in
absolutely i believe we'll start to feel
uh dramatic
repercussions for our supply chain here
in canada microchips are key components
in phones smart fridges gaming consoles
laptops and cars so be prepared for the
possibility of more delays the longer
this military conflict continues ann
gaviola global news toronto